all right this is the point in the show
where we do superlatives and uh it's
wide open it's free form and we can
basically do whatever the hell we want
to do so chris you get the first crack
at it this week oh thy grade one hand
him the mvp
give him the award now
don't make us wait till the night before
the super bowl it's over yes aaron
rodgers mvp slam dunk bam boom i mean
again
first off it's really more about aaron
rodgers you know of course aaron rodgers
is awesome yes he's the mvp of football
yes he was 10 for 10 yesterday for 150
yards in the first half and three
touchdowns yes his first incompletion of
the day was oh that's right it should
have been a 60 yard touchdown bomb that
fell through
valdez scantling's hands um but
the year he had we know i mean 48
touchdowns 48 to 5 it's the quietest 48
touchdown season we've ever had in the
history of football you know but but i
think within that too
here's the the thing to me mike i mean
green bay in my eyes i don't know if you
feel this way but over the last three
four weeks
i i've i've changed my thought on them a
little bit i don't know there just seems
to be a little bit more of a toughness
to their football team
they're able to run the ball at will on
people it's no longer just like oh this
team was playing past defense because
they worried about rogers and the
defense is gritty and tough as hell too
they make plays and of course with that
so i think differently of the packers
going to the playoffs than i did i think
at the start of december i think they
truly are the king of the nfc and rogers
is the king of all players
the road to tampa is going to go through
lambeau field we saw last sunday night
what that can mean in wintertime and
they've managed to avoid in recent weeks
and maybe they finally figured it out
maybe once you have enough of these
games where uncharacteristically you
step into a pothole and you're left to
pick up the pieces and you've got aaron
rodgers saying we just didn't have
energy today i don't know why maybe they
finally figured it out
maybe it's not a permanent affliction
that's just going to be inevitable that
it pops up from time to time maybe
they've figured out how to properly
prepare to avoid that game where we're
going to say what the hell was that so
uh you know we'll see and if it happens
it's gonna happen at home they have lost
in the time that matt lafleur has been
the head coach
two home games i believe eagles last
year and minnesota this 20 year 19 in
minnesota this year and both were games
they could have won they typically have
their clunkers
on the road they're not going to be on
the road until it's time to go back to
tampa and now they did lose in tampa 38
to 10 uh and they may cross paths with
the buccaneers again but this time it
would be at lambeau field so you know
look i i agree with you aaron rodgers
has been phenomenal more touchdown
passes than punts for the year for the
green bay packers 48 touchdown passes
and
look
mark murphy's a genius
mark murphy knows how to to to
to engineer dysfunction into a positive
i remember his comment in 2019 when
tyler dunn then of bleacher report had
the article delving into the dysfunction
between mike mccarthy the former head
coach and aaron rodgers and murphy's
reaction to all it was well if it if it
upsets some people and gets people to
perform better this year it's not a bad
thing and i really do believe at some
level as they were deciding
on this move up to get a quarterback and
all of the ramifications and between
brian goody kunst and matt lafleur and
mark murphy they're all smart enough to
know that there would have been a
reaction and there was a reaction they
managed to engineer it toward a positive
that it got aaron rodgers motivated in a
positive way much like when the patriots
drafted jimmy garoppolo in the second
round in 2014. they had gone 10 years
without winning a super bowl
they they and and there was this sense
that brady's at a crossroads right they
draft jimmy garoppolo it pisses him off
sorry london
and it helps and it works right and that
that's the win-win they have so they
have a guy now they can be groomed and
they have aaron rodgers who's salty and
he's channeled it in a positive way
right and has had one of his best
seasons ever no you're right i mean
people forget that about the bread you
know what happened there remember the
2013 afc championship game against the
broncos the broncos sold out to stop
legarrette blunt and the patriots run
game and left just wide open receivers
all over the field that day and i think
that's when new england was like what
what it might be over for him you know
either way what they've done in green
bay and we were talking in the last
break right matt lafleur
is the most underrated 26 and six head
coach i've ever heard in my life nobody
talks about him he barely gets a whisper
for coach of the year shame on us for
that i mean all of it it's just amazing
and really it's his personality
and
you know really i think almost some of
the things i perceived
as his weakness
you know getting the job oh i don't know
if he's a strong enough demeanor and
he's you know he's a little quiet i
think have all been a pot they've all
actually turned out to be positives you
know he's not too egotistical and a
narcissist or where he's got to be the
the big guy on stage all the time and
he's obviously has a great way of
communicating the right way with a guy
who we know yeah is demanding and tough
to deal with the rogers he expects a lot
and demands a lot so matt lefleur goody
everybody way to go up there in green
bay i know we gave you a lot of crap for
that draft pick not that this is a day
to wave around a doug peterson poster
but i remember when he got the job in
philadelphia that the buzz words were
emotional intelligence and it was more
more comment on the reality that they
believed chip kelly had none of it but i
think matlab floor has it in in an
abundance because you're right you don't
have to be the the hard charging my way
or the highway football coach to get the
most out of your players leflore has
found a way to get the most out of his
players and 26 and six is undeniable and
now they're the one seed in only his
second season and they have been
phenomenal and uh i think we just expect
it yeah i think it doesn't stand out
because we expect the packers to be good
and he he and that i i think it just
shows you how seamless his transition
has been
that that we're we don't even think
about him as coach of the year because
yeah we just expect this like with bill
belichick we just expect it yeah and
well it's the rogers factor
it's the rogers factor too he does that
you know he's done been doing that for
green bay for a long time we've had this
conversation when i first started on the
job you know there was a lot of years
that green bay is a super bowl contender
and you're like what the team's not
really good it's just rogers but i'm
still mad at them for picking jordan
love in the first round that was stupid
but everything else has been really good
way to go green bay
it would be very useful to have had
players who are contributing to the
cause with the first round pick and with
the fourth round pick they used to move
up in round one that's two players that
they could potentially have who'd be at
a point now where they've got 16 games
of regular season experience maybe ready
to contribute in a big way in the
postseason jordan love will not be
contributing unless uh something happens
to aaron rodgers which will make it very
hard for the packers to get to where
they want to be
my my first superlative is the ponce de
leon should have landed in tampa instead
award because when the spanish explorer
came to florida looking for the fountain
of youth uh he didn't find it well if he
had gone to tampa and picked that spot
on the water where tom brady uh
originally resided something happened
there some i mean and i've been in that
water it didn't make me it didn't save
me
we've come to expect it from tom brady
but it really is amazing this guy's now
43 years old and five months
he's got the wear and tear of a football
season
and he keeps getting better and better
and he keeps looking like the guy that
he was years ago and the buccaneers keep
getting better and better you know i i
still think they did a poor job of not
managing expectations on the way into
the season because they had some rough
spots but they've ironed out the rough
spots and i'd love to see them cross
paths with the saints again because i
think it would be far different yes
or or the loss that was dealt back in
week one when they were still getting
their feet wet getting to know each
other no preseason games that they're
they're humming now and
look tom brady's always said he's going
to play toys 45 why stop at 45
i don't know when the wheels are going
to come off for him but they're not even
starting to rattle no and he's and he's
and he's 43 in five months it truly is
amazing and this has been kind of like
his religion almost over the last 10
years that he decided at some point i am
going to
push myself deeper into my lifespan
playing football than anyone ever has
and i'm going to do it at a high level
you know george blanda was still playing
in his mid 40 but he was kicking
we've never seen anything like it don't
get used to it i don't know who else out
there can make the commitment that brady
has made and and make it work the way
that he has but it really is amazing and
uh i i think they're the most dangerous
team right now in the nfc although i
agree with you the packers
have improved
i i i hear you i think they're right
yeah they're and they're the team that i
think could give the chiefs or the bills
yeah we have to start saying or the
bills when we say chiefs now the chiefs
or the bills are run for their money i i
i agree with you there i mean totally i
totally uh they're he's on fire i mean
we just talked about him in 2013 tom
brady he's better this year than he was
in 2013 and that was seven or eight
years ago you know
again
he was at the benefit of a great system
in new england i'm not trying to take
anything away from him but what i'm
saying is this year
where i find i mean he's making plays
plays and throws sometimes where i go
well you know me mike i'm into like what
what's he do when nothing's there and is
he maximizing what's there to be had and
that's to me where brady has taken off
this year there's just so many plays
where i go well the only guy that's open
here is a he's got to throw a 45-yard
strike boom strike oh all right there's
nobody open he's gonna have to make a
perfect throw 30 yards down the field
boom perfect strike i mean his arm is
phenomenal
what's amazing is he made that scramble
to the right touchdown pass to antonio
brown i swear he's faster now than he
was in 2013.
and yeah they're flying mike i mean i
think
other than buffalo
i mean
maybe green bay in that mix i don't know
if there's a more dangerous passing
attack and i know kansas city obviously
as well right now but i don't know if
there's a better down the field passing
attack than what we've seen from the
tampa bay buccaneers over the last four
weeks and that's where they're going to
be dangerous in this nfc playoffs
i think the bye weeks this year were
critical and the later the buy the
better because that was your opportunity
to take a break
to reset
to self scout yourself
and come out of it stronger the bills
did it with a relatively late buy and it
was like week nine week ten but the
buccaneers had the latest buy yeah 13 i
think it was right and they kind of
limped into that
they have been unstoppable since
emerging from their bye week and it's
about winning games in december that was
one of the big criticisms bruce arians
had of jameis winston he had been with
quarterbacks who rose to the occasion in
december and winston went the other way
brady has risen to the occasion like
we've seen him do it before in december
he's doing it now it lays the foundation
for january and even though he's he's
soon going to be closer to 44 than 43
he is making it happen we've never had a
team play a super bowl in its home
stadium and this would be the weirdest
year to do it but it it could happen at
tampa bay green bay the old bay of pigs
right they may be the best two teams in
the nfc right now yeah i mean i would
say the way they've played yeah down the
stretch here that would be probably my
top two in the nfc but the saints being
right there i don't want to forget them
but i think just the you know the
packers in tampa have been been more
impressive i'm just i'm amazed with
everything there in tampa and brady
they're protecting them which is really
the key because as long as he's
protected he'll stand in there and make
top notch awesome throws and we're
seeing that week by week all right we
haven't talked about this game i got to
give it a little love i'm gonna give the
vince lombardi award all right a vince
lombardi award to
the baltimore ravens because you've seen
like the old vince lombardi right video
right we got a seal here and a seal here
and we're going to hit the alley right i
mean well uh yeah that's some barty's
voice well that was that little jersey
on him i don't know who that is well i
can't do the but i gave a little jersey
attitude towards it i tried to okay a
little flavor there it didn't work out
sorry but either way i know that like
the baltimore ravens offense just sealed
off the whole damn cincinnati bangles
defense yesterday i mean the whole damn
game it was unbelievable are you kidding
me 404 yards rushing in an nfl football
game that was remarkable and baltimore
just the way they're playing here coming
you know down the month of december into
january wow i mean it's really it seems
like the defense has got it going
they're healthy flying around and the
offense the run game is just unstoppable
and lamar has just found a good balance
of yeah okay i'll throw when you're open
and if you're not i'm just gonna stand
back here and i'm gonna dance and then
i'll make a bolt for something and run
for 20 yards and it's just everything's
working in baltimore right now but to
dominate the line of scrimmage like that
in an nfl football game and i know the
bengals defensive line not all that good
that still is just uh remarkable what we
saw yesterday
a second team in the super bowl era with
400 plus rushing yards in a game they
actually were threatening the record of
426 set in 1934 by the detroit lions in
a 40-7 win over the steelers and the
ravens go into the playoffs
loose
confident
and
there isn't going to be much talk
although i'm going to go ahead and
mention it now that their 0-2 with lamar
jackson as the starting quarterback and
if they fall to owen three then it
really does become a full-blown
narrative this year that's not the story
they have been in playoff mode for the
last five weeks this is just the next
game and this is their crack at the
titans you know they're going to get
maybe a chance to go on a little bit of
a revenge tour yeah teams that they've
struggled against teams that have beaten
them they're going to have a chance to
maybe beat the titans and then maybe
they get a shot at the chiefs and and uh
you know it's uh
uh it's compelling and it's a much
different vibe than last year when they
were 14 and two and uh and and the team
that you know everyone was trying to
beat and the titans did yeah it is it's
it's a different it's like last year you
know we went into it just like it's
inevitable oh the ravens are going to
win the divisional game and they're
going to go to the the afc championship
game this year they've had a fight for
it and i think they've showed us
something you know fighting for it that
they're completely capable of rising to
the challenge and i think you're right
the fact that it's been play-off game
after playoff game
really here down the stretch it's almost
made that point about lamar jackson a
little less edgy because you're just
going well
i mean okay these were all miss what
must win games and he played awesome and
won the damn game so
you know it might make us not judge
quite as harshly uh this weekend no
matter what happens
i mean we could have some serious old
school football between the ravens and
the titans with those running attacks
and that leads to my next one mike the
nfl is going that way it's going that
way sorry go ahead sorry why do you
think that is why do you think that is i
i just think and i talked about this on
my podcast a little last week because i
just think it's an it's a it's a it's a
sickle cycle cyclical league right it is
at times okay whatever but either way
you got it you got it i know you started
yes you started to fall off the cycle
right and but then you but then you got
it i've fallen off many a cycles in my
day but i i think that you know we went
to spread football all of that the
league adjusted you know they did
and of course college football's been
spread football and all those type of
things and it became a speed game and
here the last year or two we're starting
to see a few teams who are starting to
go wait these kids from college you know
they don't know how to take on a pulling
guard or a fullback leading through the
way and we're starting to see teams go
bigger on offense and stop with all the
short passing game and the bubble
screens and all that because the seattle
scheme it was an eight-man front that
kind of started to end it you know it
took away all of that stuff all the
peyton manning pick plays and all that
to where so now slowly i think you're
seeing a transformation of wait this is
the new way you know and play action and
boots are great ways to create offenses
that these defenses want to be fast with
these you know safety like linebackers
and these defensive tackles who were
athletic when complete defense and let's
start smashing their face with 330 pound
guards and tackles and i think that's
where the league is going to go here for
the next few years it'd be interesting
to watch sorry i didn't interrupt you
no no it's fine because i i'm fascinated
by this i think part of it too is the
lack of padded practices the latch
practicing of tackling to the ground
rarely are are there guys tackling to
the ground it creates for a sloppier
brand of defensive football and it
creates an opening in turn for
running games to thrive because you're
going to have missed tackles you're
going to have bad angles you're going to
have all sorts of things because you
don't practice that you know this is the
flip side of seven on seven emphasis and
defensive back play and receivers
anything right
the the
run run the ball is simple that's that's
the instinct that you have from the
first time you're playing with your
friends and somebody shows up with a
ball you run around with it but that
skill of how to properly get to the guy
who is fast and big and strong and
physical
that's something that needs to be
practiced they don't practice it like
they used to all right this this is the
eric dickerson's getting nervous award
it's something that mike taurico said on
the digital clip that we did last night
that he was texting with jim gray who
was texting with eric dickerson who was
very nervous during the titans game
that it was going to go to overtime
because dickerson feared that it went to
overtime derek henry was going to
surpass 2105 yards for the season he
came within 79. it is amazing derrick
henry is amazing and you know they say
don't pay running backs well for every
running back that got paid and
went south you've got derek henry you've
got alvin kamara you've got dalvin cook
they got paid and they have
provided a great return on their
investment mike i mean derek derrick
henry
you know it sometimes it takes a little
while to get going
but once it gets going it's incredible
2027 yards the eighth player in nfl
history with 2 000 rushing yards in the
season and the titans are the first team
to have two of them they had chris
johnson yeah 2009 and now they have
derrick henry in 2020 chris yeah really
it's it's amazing what we watch him do
every week it is it's just it's again
one of the unstoppable forces in
football for the most part and if you
just give him any daylight at all
you know and like you said he gets his
momentum going forget it i mean he can
just run by you he can make you miss he
runs you over it's just it's it's
amazing it really is he's he's one of
the more special running backs we've
ever seen in the game and it's just when
you watch him run
i don't think you know tv does him
justice sometimes just because you watch
him go it doesn't look like he's moving
that fast but then you're sitting there
and you're going wait that guy that's
chasing him runs 4-4 like and he's
running away from him and that's where
it's just amazing week after week he
answers the bell and he handles himself
the right way he's a lot of he's very
easy to root for that's for sure
all right you got any more yeah i got
lots more i mean i mean i got lots more
all right um
i i think we got to hit this
the are we sure isn't going to mean my
are we sure are we sure
are we sure about tua that's where i i
think i got to go with this here you
know we didn't get to talk about it
because we we waxed poetically again
about the buffalo bills
but
going into a 2021 off season tool was a
top five pick
you know at no
at no point during the year
did he show to be anywhere in the same
stratosphere as joe burrow or justin
herbert no point
i i just i'm just i got questions that's
all i'm saying you know listen
they were handicapped yesterday by
by the fact that he was playing
quarterback they have to manage the game
there's limited to what they can do as
soon as they fall fell behind we kind of
were like ah we know it's over he's not
going to drop back and beat them with
his arm and make throws like that and
listen i don't care that they lost
or that the statistics aren't that great
it's not passing the eye test that's all
it's about it's not personal the kid is
awesome because i get a lot of crap from
miami fans on social media it's i the
kid is awesome i'm just talking about
football it does not pop and that's
gotta concern the miami dolphins a
little bit going in the off season
yeah and look i think you're putting it
mildly i i i continue to be bothered by
right this okay and dolphins fans get
upset but it's a very simple proposition
they had the fifth pick
they had tua or justin herbert they
could have taken either one and the fact
that they took tua
and that the chargers took justin
herbert with the very next pick
amplifies all of it that's right and it
creates a a a dotted line
from
la to miami
for the next 10 years or as as long as
they're both in the nfl and uh that's
just the reality and when when you're
you know it when when you're standing on
the brink of that pick it's no different
than peyton manning versus ryan leaf
it's just in a different spot of the
draft you've got two elite quarterbacks
left and i've got people who were saying
yesterday that nobody knew justin
herbert was going to be good he wasn't a
top prospect are you kidding me do you
not pay attention to what goes on of
course he was of course he was a top
prospect the biggest question about him
was
if you drag him too far away from oregon
is he going to be able to function
remember that was that was the number
and uh they dragged him from oregon down
to l.a and he's been perfectly fine so i
think they could have pulled him to
miami and we've seen it and as you say
it's the eye test it's what does it look
like what does it feel like and with
justin herbert it looks different it
feels different it feels better much
better and looks much better than what
tua has done and
it hurts me to say it because i think
two is a great kid exactly and i think
it's a great story right and i want him
to do well right but if i if i was a
dolphins hand right now i would be
agonizing over the fact that we got the
wrong guy yeah period yeah no i mean
it's tough herbert is special you know i
didn't expect these type of results but
as you know last year i mean during the
draft process he was my number two
quarterback and i said i think he has a
higher ceiling than joe burrow he has
superstar talent and it's been justified
now i mean it's so justified that i want
to go hello hello los angeles chargers
please call brian dayball and start the
arms race with their kansas city chiefs
and just go that way you know no
disrespect to eric b enemy i just want
to say this i wouldn't hire a
coordinator from a team within my
division to be a copycat of that team
you you're not going to dethrone the
king bring in a new idea let eric the
enemy go to the houston texans with
deshaun watts and let them light it up
but i just look at that and go yeah
herbert's been special but not to change
the subject yes the tua thing is
concerning dolphins have a lot of draft
picks everything like that fitzpatrick
getting up there in years i just i'll
i'll be interested to see what they do
at the quarterback position this
offseason they got the third overall
pick i know the third overall pick
thanks to the houston texans how do you
not engage you have to evaluate all the
quarterbacks anyway because you may be
in a position to do a trade we don't
know how it's all going to fall together
at the top of the draft you've got to
fully evaluate the quarterbacks and in
the process of evaluating the
quarterbacks you may decide
we think we got somebody
better than tua and it may be josh rosen
all over again you can't rule that out
right at this stage of the game you
can't because there's a lot of work
still to be done we still have a lot
that we need to
do hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports